so welcome back
everybody um on stage with us we have
James Powell who came all the way from
from America he is board chair at num
focus and he's going to present to us a
talk that didn't have a title yet but
it's titled a cumulative index Max so a
round of applause for James
[Applause]
please hello everybody this is cumul
index Max we're at Pi Amsterdam it is
September 15th 2023 my name is James
Powell you can follow me on whatever
platforms are still around to follow
people on I'm basically James Powell or
don't use this code on all of those
platforms for those of you who have seen
some of the talks that I've given on
YouTube you may have seen earlier this
year at Pi data London I gave a talk on
grouped weighted summary statistics and
pandas which turns out to be a very
useful but difficult problem to solve in
that talk I had discovered something
extraordinary I had discovered the four
words when put into a talk title
constitute the most boring talk title
ever created grouped weighted summary
statistics but I have something exciting
for you today I have found an even more
boring talk title and only three words
cumulative index maximums so in this
talk what I want to share with you is
some of the thought process that arose
when thinking through the problem that
was discussed in group weighted summary
statistics specifically cases where
pandas is simply not fast enough or
simply does not implement the mechanisms
necessary to solve useful problems and
what you do in response additionally how
we can think about optimizing code
especially where we have to optimize
code by working around deficiencies
limitations or missing features of tools
that we use so let's take a look now I
want to set up the problem for you and
so for cumulative index Max the problem
setup is actually fairly straightforward
let's assume that we have a data frame
and in that data frame we have dates we
have tickers and we have prices very
very common data set used in many sort
of financial analyses here you can see
the data is randomly generated and for
the most part we don't really care
exactly what the data is other than that
it constitutes some random walk over 180
days with 100 different names if we have
this data set and we think about the
analysis we might do on that data set it
stands to reason that one of the more
common analysis you might do is to
figure out what is the minimum price
what's the maximum price very common
analysis that may come up similarly what
is the day where the minimum or the
maximum price occurred also a very
common analysis we want to know when we
hit those extents although you can see
unfortunately in pandas it doesn't
really know how to deal with that
multi-index properly and so as a
consequence we get something a little
bit noisy we get the day and the ticker
but the ticker is repeated so we end up
needing to do this a little bit a little
bit more clumsily in pandas to get the
result we want unfortunately the new
group Keys argument that's provided to
us in group by doesn't actually remove
the extra group layering in this case it
would for example remove the extra suers
group group key layering when we do say
a doly operation but here what we have
to do is we actually have to break this
down into a userdefined function pass to
act and so here we have something very
useful on the 15th of January one of
these tickers saw its minimum price on
the 8th of April it saw its maximum
price
similarly we might want to do a
cumulative minimum and a cumulative
maximum as we go through the data set we
want to figure out okay given this
cumulative minimum cumulative maximum
what is the highest price we've seen so
far what's the lowest price we've seen
so far can give us some information
about say the extents of where this
pricing might arise and given that data
we could do something interesting like
we could say subtract it from the series
and figure out how far away we are from
our minimum or maximum except one of the
unfortunate things about pandas is it is
very easy to use pandas without really
knowing what we're doing and really
knowing how index alignment works and
when we do that we end up with these
horrible tracebacks with error messages
we can't make heads or tails of cannot
join with no overlapping index names
well unfortunately I've tried to do an
index alignments between a data frame
and a series and I've forgotten that
when we index align a data frame against
a series it aligns the index of the
series against The Columns of the data
frame so the solution here is quite
simple I just have to create a secondary
data frame that index aligns properly
where the column names of that secondary
data frame or the column names of the
First Data frame and now I have
something fairly useful this is the
distance from the minimum or the maximum
price for every day in my data set and
you can think of this very similarly to
if I want to do some kind of expanding
Zed score or if I wanted to do some kind
of normalization how many standard
deviations am I away from the maximum
that I've seen so far will be a very
useful analysis the thing is when I take
this data set and I think about those
kind of operations these cumulative mins
and these minimum
actually come up quite often even an
index Min operation may come up quite
often for example it may be the case
that I don't want to just find where the
price what the price was when it was
lowest I want to find what day that
occurred on and when we think about
pandas we often think about pandas in
terms of this index as the core coherent
metaphor it's the mechanism which
defines the semantics of almost every
operation in pandas and we can think
largely that when we talk about a pandas
data frame we're not talking about a two
structure we're talking about a
one-dimensional structure some
collection of entities where those
entities have aspects that have been
represented in their columns it's a very
classical struct of arrays array of
structs type of transformation and as a
consequence on an arbitrary data frame
we may do minimum and maximum operations
or cumulative minimum maximum operations
we could express those in terms of
expanding minimum and maximum operations
although we get the exact same result
just as for example a fold over add is
the same thing as a sum operation or or
a fold over Min is the same thing as
just the Min
operation it's often the case that we
want to do an index Min or an index Max
and the reason we want to do that is to
do some sort of lateral query for
example we want to know for this data
set what are the values of a where we
see the lowest value of B we want to do
some sort of lateral analysis and this
is how this is why we would use the
index Min or the index Max because we'd
say that the index is what's tying
together these disparate data sets or
what's tying these different Columns of
these data sets so we'd first do an
index Max on B and then do a lookup on a
it's very common way that we do these
lateral these lateral analysis
historically as you know pandas did not
have the key function protocol
implemented like the max the Min and the
sorted in pure python which is how we'd
solve these problems in pure python
instead we have to go through this
subordinate structure through this index
in order to solve the problem similarly
it's not too uncommon for us to do some
very complex things with this sort of
index construction for example this
analys here i'llbe it very clumsy and
with a lot going on is just finding what
are the values of B which where B is
around one standard deviation I should
actually fix a small typo in here the
values where B is around one standard
deviation of its Min and a is around one
standard deviation from its Max and we
do that by setting up figure out where a
meets this criteria give me the index
and do an index double intersection and
then finally at the very end actually
look up the data this is why for example
for those of you who have followed me on
any platforms you may have heard me
threaten that the next version of pandas
or the the tool that replaces pandas
might be a tool that is just indices
only because ultimately a lot of the
analyses are really just happening on
the index and the data surprisingly
enough is quite secondary in fact in
truth in many cases I don't care about
the data I care much more about the
indices but that might be a little bit
too controversial for all of you
unfortunately what is missing in pandas
is a cumulative index Min or cumulative
index Max this is simply and completely
missing and it is an incredibly useful
thing to solve very real problems you
have cumulative Min you have index men
but you don't have the combination of
the two and the reason for that is
something which you can imagine there
might be some debate over what the API
for that might look like as we'll see
there are some variations on how we
might model that but for the most part
the truth of the matter is many of the
tools that we use such as pandas are
tools that are under active development
they are tools that are not complete and
in maintenance mode but they are tools
that are constantly adding new features
and we still risk to this day that
something that we need to do is not yet
implemented and we have to figure out
what do we do in the interim of time
between when we discover we have this
problem and when the pandas core
developers have the time to go and solve
that assuming of course that we
ourselves are not willing to put the
effort into fixing pandas now I will say
when I discovered that we were missing
this I went into the panda source code
and tried to see how much work it would
be to add in accumulative index Min and
accumulative index Max cuz I thought if
index in and index Max already exist
isn't it just a cut and paste job
unfortunately that's not the case it is
also that libraries like pandas are very
complex and they have many layers of
indirection and it does take a while for
you to become familiar with how you can
slot in these new methods it is not an
easy feat to add some new functionality
pandas for a library of its level of
maturity so facing that I wonder how do
I go about Sol solving this problem and
again really all we're looking for are
analyses where we have some entities and
we're trying to figure out some sort of
lateral query of the entity where in
pure python we would do this with just
Max and a key function but we're stuck
at the python speed or we'd even do
these kind of analyses with some kind of
comprehensions but you can see the
comprehension syntax is very clumsy here
there's a lot that's missing when we
don't have the ability to quickly just
access Columns of this data pandas is
more than just a convenience level on
top of numpy and D arays it adds some
very meaningful apis for accessing
aspects of the data in a fashion that's
much less clumsy and much more fluent
than what you can do in pure Python and
whereby that API allows you to encode
the operations you want to do within a
restricted computation domain in other
words you can do them not at python
speed but at C- speed at the speed of
whatever pandas is built on top of and
so with that said in the absence of in
this case a group by cumulative index
Min or cumulative index Max we have to
figure out how we want to structure this
ourselves and naturally just as index
Min and index Max or just an expanding
Min or expanding Max we might think we
could start with the expanding operation
and then get in the index Min or index
Max unfortunately there is no index Min
or index Max attached to expanding
otherwise this problem would already be
solved and unfortunately as many of you
know the expanding API recently became
much more restrictive historically the
expanding API would allow us to do
pretty much anything we wanted to within
a user defined function so for example
we could write a userdefined function
and in this user defined function we
could just do index Min and call it a
day except the expanding API these days
requires that all of the operations done
in a userdefined function are done only
on numeric columns and you can think why
is that well this is very meaningful for
us if we think about what makes Panda's
code fast and what makes Panda's code
slow what makes Panda's code fast are
cases where we can with some generality
drop down to the lower level we can tell
the Panda's API to do something and then
it figures out how to encode that in
operations at these lower level
structures whether numpy level
structures or arol level structures and
in the case of an expanding you can
think you lose extreme generality in
order to be able to say okay I have some
operation I want to perform it on every
single subset of this data fundamentally
any UDF that you perform on an expanding
data structure is going to be performed
rowwise because you have to perform it
on one row then two rows then three rows
and four rows therefore the expanding
API fundamentally is is going to operate
at python speed so what's the point of
it in the first place if you're already
at python speed you might as well just
write a python Loop which I think gives
a reasonable justification for why they
limited the scope of the expanding API
the panda core developers probably
assessed that you know what we're at
python speed anyway if we allow people
to do anything they want you don't need
a special API to just write a python for
Loop and so the answer for this question
may be what if we just write a simple
python for Loop and do things that we
are told we are not supposed to do in
pandas we are not supposed to it rows we
are not supposed to do it do items we
are not supposed to operate row by row
question is how bad could it really be
if we do that and so a python
implementation of cumulative index Max
fairly straightforward we create a
return value that's index similarly to
what we past we write a for Loop
operating over the dot items for a
series that's the equivalent of the do
it rows and this code here is about the
dumbest code for figuring out a Max that
you ever saw this is your computer
science 101 version of a Max which by
the way is a good thing because as we'll
see when we have to work around the
deficiencies of some of these projects
or the gaps in these projects I think
that it's generally a good case where
the workaround that we have is written
in the dumbest possible code that we can
write in part because we understand that
the temporality the transientness of our
workaround it's not going to be around
forever the panas developers will
eventually solve this problem and we
really don't want to put a lot of effort
into writing maintaining understanding
validating the code and so that I can
write this in a couple of lines of very
very stupid code is actually a very good
thing and I can do that and I can time
it and it takes me about a half a second
to operate on this data and you can see
I can even do the subtraction from the
original data set so I can answer a
question of how many days since the last
time you saw a high price this
cumulative index Max problem on this
data set is enormously valuable this
answers the question of how many days
since you were last at your maximum
price which you can imagine if you've
watched even a small amount of CNBC is
an easy way for the people on CNBC to
fill time with nothing of actual
knowledge or interest or value to say oh
this is the last time that we've seen
this price in 32.4 days well now I've
automated it we don't even need a highly
paid anchor to be able to spit out this
level of basically empty financial news
but in other cases we may actually
discover that there is some real value
to this problem and I think there's
actually some real value here now when
we talk about these workarounds one of
the things that we need to talk about
for these workarounds is to what degree
do we want to generalize these do we
want to create an API and in the group
weighted summary statistics problem we
discovered that actually generalizing
that API writing something that would
solve all the different versions of
problems that people might have without
unnecessarily precluding some version of
this problem is actually quite difficult
there's a lot of Dynam a lot of areas
this but for cumulative index Max is
actually quite simple you could think
that the only modality that you might
see on a cumulative index Max is what
happens when you have the max visited
multiple times do you take the first
date of the max or do you take the last
date of the max or do you take all of
them and in some cas Cas you might want
to say when was the earliest time that
we saw the maximum value when was the
latest time that we saw the maximum
value if we Revisited that maximum value
or what are all the times we saw that
maximum value and so this this
cumulative index Max has a very simple
modality it's just earliest latest or
all and that's about all that you really
need to consider in order to implement
something like this however there is
generality in terms of the underlying
data structure that you're operating on
well if we take that into
consideration and we try to implement
our cumulative index Max we see the
speed is not too bad it's a little bit
clumsy to use this as a consequence of
my formulation this code's a little bit
clumsy you see a little bit of ugliness
around needing to drop this extra level
this is a very common thing that we see
in pandas with these multi-indices
sometimes when we do a group eye on one
of these levels that level is present in
the group itself so you have to drop it
so that you don't end up with these
accidental duplications of these levels
but for the most part it's
straightforward as long as we can get
this speed to where we want it to be now
this was5 seconds on 18,000 rows what
happens if we try to apply this problem
to a slightly more realistic data set
let's take the same construction of that
data set and instead of looking at just
180 days and 100 names let's look at 10
years and a thousand names so we'll
create a brand new data set with about
3.5 million rows not humongous well
within what we expect to be efficient in
pandas and let us try our python
implementation with the python loop with
the dot items with our cumulative index
Max and when we do this we see exactly
why we are told do not do ad do items do
not do ad do itos do not operate in
pandas row by row at the python level
because I ran this code about 5 seconds
ago it is still running and in fact if
we take those 0.5 seconds and we
multiply them times the 18,000 or so
rows and then multiply it up times the
3.5 million rows in our slightly more
representative data set we could see
this is an 87c problem I don't think
that's within the range of what we
consider to be fast enough and in fact
when I think about the speed of these
operations there's a tension I find that
when I go online and people talk about
I've written the fastest version of this
the fastest version of this it is a very
valid Counterpoint to say no the code
that we've written here is genuinely
fast enough but it's also a valid point
to say well if your data set is growing
as many of the data sets that we work on
and they grow very quickly over time and
you can measure that the data set grows
maybe super linearly over time maybe
what's fast enough today won't be fast
enough tomorrow and in fact many of you
know this is the danger
of poorly implemented algorithms
specifically super linear algorithms
like n algorithms because on your
testing data set they are fast enough
but the moment it hits the real data set
that exponentiation makes it so slow
that everything grinds to a halt well in
this particular case you know what I'm
short on time and I'm very impatient
trust me 87 seconds is way too slow and
I think I can do better and the question
is how do I do better I want to use this
as an opportunity to talk a little bit
about something that we see more and
more on the various platforms that we
might use that is the idea of Benchmark
Gore because between you and me when we
talk about making code faster it is very
easy for somebody to post on LinkedIn or
on X or on blue sky or whatever platform
they happen to use or whatever platform
that everybody has decided we don't want
to use anymore the idea that it is
Meaningful and useful to say I just
rewrote function f and it is 2.2% faster
and it is a very useful thing to post if
you want followers because they get lots
of likes and they get lots of retweets
or whatever the equivalent is on
whatever other platform that we're using
I don't know what we're using these days
I'm on to Tik Tok so whatever the Tik
Tok equivalent is well you get a lot of
Engagement But ultimately I'm not
certain that that's actually meaningful
and I'm not certain that we should
really read too much into it because
fundamentally when I think about
benchmarking and I think about taking
some code and making it faster I think
about it in terms of three major
characteristics one is this Improvement
durable at the last pataa Amsterdam
pataa Amsterdam Fest that was held
online I gave a talk called Fast and
Furious 7 something something python
performance because I thought we've seen
a million talks on python performance
and at the time we'd seen a million
movies based on The Fast and Furious
franchise here's yet another one that
will bore you to death in that talk one
of the things that I showed was micro
optimizations that occur at the python
level are not durable that is to say if
you take two pieces of python code and
you see which one's faster you actually
measure which is faster it is very
likely that when you upgrade your python
version the faster one and the slower
one will invert and when you upgrade
your python version again they'll invert
again and what I discovered over the
versions of python that I had access to
at the time was that in some cases small
micro optimizations were not durable as
all of the tools that we build our code
on top of the version of python the
version of the underlying libraries
update the fastest version becomes the
slowest version and the slowest version
becomes the fastest version and thus
that Benchmark or is simply not useful
because what I want is either something
that is fast enough meeting to some sort
of metric or I want the fastest possible
and just knowing that I can for example
do a map versus a I don't know I think
the example was a map with a Lambda or a
map with a c function or something like
that whatever the case is it's not
helpful for me to be able to get
something to be the fastest only at one
tiny narrow point in time additionally I
think about these in terms of the
robustness because when you look at the
Benchmark or it's often the case that
these are presented as though there's
something you can learn from them
but when you really dig into them some
of these benchmarks are only applicable
to exactly the code that you're looking
at they're not robust that is to say if
I take that Benchmark and the approach
that is suggested in that Benchmark and
apply to my actual example I may not see
the speed up that you have and thus good
great you made your code faster what
does it do for me and finally I think
about these in terms of generality one
of the tricks that you can use if you
want to publish Benchmark or is you can
find aspects of these problem s that are
of low generality that is to say you can
specify certain details assuming you
have a data frame that doesn't have a
multi-index and it has a datetime index
with datetime 64 NS data types and the
data types of all of the columns are in
64s then you can make this faster but in
many cases as you all know what looks so
easy online ends up being very difficult
for you to apply to your actual work
because there's small aspects where your
problem differs from the problem they
solve you need some additional
generality you need to break the
assumption that the index values are
unique or that they're in sorted order
and then your benchmark is no longer
applicable and that Benchmark is not
actually providing you with any useful
information and so when I look at a
problem like this cumulative index Max
and I try and think what am I going to
do about it well I don't know that I can
guarantee that I can give you a
particularly General answer I can
guarantee that I can give you a durable
answer I can guarantee that there are
some approaches that we can take to work
around deficiencies in pandas
specifically not operating at the python
level that will be durable as versions
of pandas improve my version will not be
slower it's just that pandas may catch
up they may add fast pads or they may
add functionality that catches up to
what I can do in terms of robustness
you'll see that different approaches
that we might take may or may not have a
little bit of tension around robustness
and in terms of generality I would say
that if we approach some of these
optimization problems as narrowly and as
shallowly and as as quickly and as
efficiently as we can that is to say we
don't put a lot of effort into them we
try and write very shallow approaches on
top of the existing tool approaches
approaches that we assume will be
transient that we assume we will throw
away at some point in the future we can
sometimes argue our way out of needing
to actually generalize to all versions
of the problem so the first version of
this that I wrote I thought what could
be easier I'll just take my dumb my dumb
python code and I'll use number and I
think n is actually a very valid
approach because we preserve all of the
generality of the existing code that we
have we preserve presumably the
robustness of this approach you know if
it worked for me it'll probably work for
you and in terms of the durability
generally what we say is if P if Numba
didn't speed up your code you just take
off The Decorator and you're no worse
off than you were before you only use it
if it's faster and therefore you get you
are guaranteed some durability well in
truth and let's make sure that I have
that installed but in truth even if I
look at the timing this particular
version spits out a million different
errors and unfortunately let me actually
switch over to my version that doesn't
use my Mamba
container there we go spits out a bunch
of errors and it's still not
particularly fast and unfortunately one
thing that I think creates a lot of
tension in our use of a tool like Numba
is I probably need to rewrite this
python code to be more amenable to the
optimizations that Numba can see because
you can see all of these warnings that
are being spit out are because NBA can't
really see through the Panda's data
structure can't see through the panda
series and and I'm beginning to enter
territory that I'm getting a little bit
uncomfortable in because if I have to
change my python code in order to make
it faster with num I I'm now beginning
to think well if I remove the number
decorator do I end up with python code
that's worse than the original code that
I wrote and you can see where I'm
beginning to risk losing durability or
losing robustness of this but if I do a
little bit of work I'll still get a
million errors sped out but I might
actually be able to get number to speed
this up just a little bit I think in my
test this should take about 5 seconds so
so you'll see that I get maybe a 20 yep
you can see I got a result from this in
about 10 seconds so I got an eight time
speed up without too much additional
work what I have found in the case of
pandas is that it's actually a
surprisingly useful technique to just
drop down to numpy where numpy is
available or hopefully in cases where
you're backing everything with arrow to
drop down to the equivalent there
because in truth with just a little bit
of numpy cod and slightly clever numpy
cod as you can see that's here I can
actually recover much of the speed that
I lose from the slowness of operating on
the row by row level in pandas and I
didn't really need to write that much
code you can see here I'm at 83 seconds
so it's about 100 times speed up which I
think is is worthwhile going from a
minute to under a second does genuinely
bring some value to my life and
generally does suggest that as my data
sets grow I might have a little bit more
leeway before I have to try something
more exotic or more esoteric than this
additionally with this approach you can
see it's not that much code so I'm not
going to really invest too much time in
validating it in testing it or in
feeling bad when I have to replace it
when something better comes along now
with this in mind one of the other
approaches that I showed in the problem
related to group weighted summary
statistics is what happens when you drop
down to scon and I've discovered that if
you start with numpy just pulling out
the numpy and D arrays and seeing if you
can operate on those you can actually
get surprising speed speedups over what
pandas can give you even in some of
these cases specifically in cases where
pandas just doesn't Implement something
and you can do that at an implementation
level that's very shallow meaning you do
it once you slot it into your code you
put uh extra context manager to warn you
when Panda's updates or you put a
comment or you you add a task to your
calendar check Panda's version 3.0 and
see if they fixed this yet and then
remove it whatever the case may be and
syon also gives you quite a bit of an
approach for this and so in an Endeavor
to try and see if I could speed this up
I also implemented a version of syon
here but what you can see with the scon
version is I'm beginning to lose
generality I'm beginning to seriously
lose generality because I have to assume
for example that I'm looking at just a
datetime 64 NS index which I'm not one
of the interesting things about the
numpy approach is the numpy approach
only requires that I have a greater than
less than relationship on the dtype
that's supported within numpy if I need
generality like I need a dtype like an
object D type this code will still work
it'll just drop down to the python data
model in order to assess what's larger
or smaller than whatever and I can then
go into numpy and maybe think about
implementing a d type or re-encoding
that data as a dtype that numpy is aware
of but the moment I drop down to syon I
start to get into trouble because when I
look at this you can see I have long I
have double and if I really want to get
even a small amount of generality here
like for example the column may not be
float 64 but may in fact be in 64d types
I have to start duplicating this code
with additional maintenance burden of
having a version of this that works on
doubles a version of this that works on
integers and so forth and so on and so
where I have found that the scyon
approach is very beneficial is cases
where you really do need to write just
the dumbest possible for Loop you can
like the group weighted summary
statistics example and where the speed
up is maybe 10 times or more over the
pure numpy version which we saw in the
group weighted summary s we've got to
about a thousand times speed up over
what you can do with a do a group I
applying pandas and where you can suffer
that loss of generality of basically
specifying that these are you know Longs
and doubles and an index of a particular
formulation and you can write it as
specific to your problem as possible you
see this a lot in the python standard
Library as well the python standard
Library often struggles because
sometimes parts of the standard Library
are way too General to solve the parts
of the problem that you want I have for
many years complained about the ABC
module in the standard Library it's
useful if you're a core developer but
you can write a better more specific
more useful version of it in about 10
lines using a meta class or an IT subass
and similarly in other parts of the
Python standard Library they're way too
General they solve problems that you
don't necessarily have and as a
consequence they're slower or less
efficient than what you can write
yourself and finding that exact targeted
just general enough to solve the
problems I have but not too specific
well this is where if you can find that
and Target that I think the scyon
approach is a valid approach if we
actually try the timing of this scon
approach we will discover unfort in this
case we don't really get much of a speed
up we might be able to eek out another
15% or 20% if we really drop down if we
really TI and tear away the pandas
layers and then reconstitute them bear
in mind we are paying for additional
costs here like the cost of Performing
that view operation there's a couple of
small costs that we have to pay here to
pull the data out we don't really have
to pay much of a cost to put it back in
but whatever the case may be at 15% at
20% I don't think the loss of generality
is actually worth it and so what I
wanted share with you here is not to
bore you to death about cumulative index
Max which trust me is a very very
interesting problem just as group
weighted summary statistics is but
instead to get you to think about places
where the tools that we're using really
are in underactive development there are
places where they simply are not
finished there are places where we
ourselves can contribute to fill in the
gaps cumulative index Max is a little
bit more than an afternoon of somebody's
work but it would be a good starting
project where somebody wanted to get
involved in Panda's development and how
we might think about solving these kinds
of problems in terms of actually getting
durable robust generalizable results as
opposed to just seeing something online
that says I made this 2.3% faster
downloading it putting a lot of energy
into it and then discovering it doesn't
actually do anything for you well this
has been cumulative index Max my name is
James poell thank you all for joining
us I think we have time for
very
thank you thank you James